welcome back to cbs this morning
critics are blasting the approval of a
controversial new drug to help treat
alzheimer's disease
the first patient who was not part of a
clinical trial got the drug last week
clinical trials showed it may reduce
amyloid plaque believed to be a marker
of alzheimer's disease
but it's not clear whether it delays or
prevents
actual symptoms the fda's independent
advisory committee recommended the
agency reject the drug when the fda
ignored that advice
three committee members resigned
including dr
aaron kesselheim first on cbs this
morning our dr
tara narula spoke with dr kessel heim
who's a faculty member at brigham and
women's hospital in boston
he explained why he resigned from the
committee
in your resignation letter you called
the adlham
approval the worst drug approval in u.s
history
why do you say that the drug showed no
good evidence that it worked
because it had important side effects
and then the fda is totally switching
gears over the last six months
and approving this drug on the basis of
a theory relating to the surrogate
marker of
amyloid plaques that we as an advisory
committee back in november
were told to to not consider and if the
fda
allows companies to get drugs approved
on the basis
of um you know trials that are stopped
early trials that are reanalyzed
that sets a precedent because it tells
other companies well
i don't also i don't need to to run a
you know a rigorous
um trial either what message do you hope
to send to the fda by resigning
patients and physicians really do depend
on the fda maintaining
uh reasonable standards for for the
drugs that it provides
in the you know majority of cases
you know i like to think that the fda
makes the makes the right decision
in cases like this where the fda makes
what i think is the wrong decision
i think that that we need to understand
better why the decisions were made in
this way
and dr narula joins us now good morning
good morning michelle good to see you so
the fda approved this drug
without the recommendation of his
committee i mean how how
how often do they do this this is pretty
uncommon so 80 percent of the time
there's concordance between what the
advisory committee recommends and what
the fda does
in the 20 percent of time where there's
discordance three quarters of those are
instances where the advisory committee
recommends
for the drug and the fda actually says
no or puts limitations on it so this is
pretty rare
and when i spoke to dr kesleheim about
what really pushed him to resign there
were a couple things i think the first
was the big feeling
that the fda in this case did not follow
the science that there was really a lack
of efficacy for this drug
and significant concern for side effects
you know a third of the patients had
brain hemorrhage or bleeding
there was a question about why this lack
of transparency in his mind why this big
180 degree shift
from the committee being told don't
review it on the basis of surrogate
endpoints like amalek to suddenly that's
actually how they approved it
why wasn't the advisory committee called
back to assess
this idea of a circuit endpoint and then
the third issue is really
how this frustration over how are the
advisory committee's recommendations
being integrated and used
he actually pointed to a similar
approval of a muscular dystrophy drug
several years ago
where he was on the committee they voted
against it it was a surrogate endpoint
and the fda pushed it through
without really explaining why so we need
to note
tara that biogen the maker of this drug
says it submitted
to the fda millions of pages of data and
analysis from
eight clinical trials the fda said in a
statement
our review has been thorough so why are
critics like
dr kesselheim still not satisfied well
anthony there are several other issues i
think one of them
centers around this idea that the biogen
company was given nine years
after the approval to perform a
confirmatory study to show efficacy
and according to dr kessleheim the drugs
that were used to
approve this the trials that were used
to approve this took four years so why
is this now
why are they being given nine years uh
in previous history of drugs that were
approved under accelerated approval
pathways many times there was delays
in these confirmatory trials if the
studies were negative the drugs were not
then pulled off the market and so this
is a significant period of time where
there can be harm to patients both
financially
and medically and then another issue
around labeling so this drug was studied
in patients with mild alzheimer's
disease who had proven
imaging of amyloid plaques but the label
says it can be used for all patients
with alzheimer's disease
without really being clear about whether
they need imaging proof
of amyloid and then finally is this
really going to push the research
away from other therapies that might be
helpful
to drugs like this and there have been
dozens and dozens of other drugs that
have looked at removing amyloid
and not shown efficacy rare disagreement
between the fda and its committee
also noteworthy that these families want
hope and if this doesn't provide it
that's very concerning that's right dr
terran thank you very much
coming up